greetings
uh let's see there's several
many things i wanted to talk about today
uh and the first of which is uh is the
following
whoops
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's tracy's birthday today
many half returns now the next
the agenda um
uh i had this little quotation there
there's been several things in the media
about writing i guess writing is uh more
people are beginning to realize a
big part of a big part of our life and
so
so that was in last week i think
and one of the
one of my favorites was
russell baker's column
two or three weeks ago do you remember
do you remember this one would any of
you run across this uh it's very hard to
get a headline like this through the
systems these days
um
but uh but here he's talking about
using his word processor
uh okay now man
so
man's quest is eternal but
what specifically is it that he quests
and why does he know mankind's quest is
man's and woman's quest mankind's and
womankind's quest humanities quest for
the perfect writing device eternal has
been humanity's question
eternal have have been many of humanity
from the earliest cave writing
eternal has been the quest for a device
that will forever prevent writers from
using words
now
but he succeeded here i think in
capturing the thoughts that go through a
writer's mind when writing it when
writing an essay
so it's easier to revise and edit with a
computer
than with a typewriter or pencil this
amazing machine makes it very hard to
stop editing and revising long enough to
write a readable sentence much less an
entire column
um
so that's uh
uh anyway that
that was one another here's uh paul paul
hands me this from last friday's new
york times
um
he didn't acknowledge where he had
stolen something and put a noose around
his thick neck quotes can be dangerous
if you don't acknowledge the source okay
so here we are acknowledging the source
new york times friday the
right of the 13th
um i got
a alumni magazine from caltech
and take a look at this
cover picture here it's it's uh has a
picture of one of my heroes on the cover
um
guess which
guess which gentleman it is and uh but
it talks about the story of uh of uh for
of professor flyman uh
uh
uh and uh
and uh his uh
uh
his reminiscences of serving on the
challenger
on the panel that investigated the
challenger disaster last year
and
he has
so
so he uh
uh has
not not um
he has a terrific sense of humor i think
for the among all the uh people that
have been able to write
humorous things uh
and uh with
uh in science uh
besides being of course a brilliant
scientist nobel prize winner and
everything else uh he has uh a way of
giving a lecture if you ever have a
chance to hear
to hear him uh uh he can convey
technical
stuff and still amuse you
simultaneously better than anybody else
you know but he's but he's talking here
about uh
about um
this is a transcript of a talk that he
gave and he
and he starts out
and he says uh
before i tell you about the shuttle i
thought it would be interesting to you
all to see the costume that i assumed in
order to move around the natives without
being too conspicuous in washington they
wear this kind of coat because it's a
little bit cold there snow sometimes
he's a professor of capacity in caltech
of course
and so then he talks about it so then he
says uh
now that you've seen the equipment i'm
going to take it off and everything so
that was undoubtedly the suit that he's
shown with on the cover of this magazine
here now but then
immediately he goes into a discussion of
of the challenger and uh in a way that
even i could understand
what um
what the technical
problems were and then he got through
that quickly in a few phases but then he
starts you know so then he talks about
the uh the issues about the commissions
it's really uh
um
i really enjoyed reading this article
well the thing i wanted to show you was
some of the
the things that that he that he
commented on um had to do with
with writing
in the middle of this um
uh so let's see where are we um
oh here's one um
so the only time i expected we would be
meeting in washington discuss it we had
found out so far to think it out
together and look at it from different
perspectives in addition to the
astronauts on the panel there were
lawyers industrialists there were
scientists and engineers and so on and
to discuss with each other where to go
with each each other whoops
where to go next so um but in our
meetings all we ever did was what they
called word smithing correcting
punctuation refining phrases and so on
we never had a real discussion of ideas
besides the word smithing we discussed
the type of typography and the color of
the cover at each meeting we were asked
to vote so i thought it would be
efficient to vote for the same color we
had decided on in the meeting before the
turnout i was always in the minority we
finally chose red it came out blue
well uh
no you know any any humorous could give
these lines but he was a he he uh uh
made some some decent points here and
and i find uh um
uh
also though that that his emphasis on on
on wordsmithing is uh you know he's he's
he's giving it
um
a negative thing but it is becoming part
of our lives more more uh
that we um
that we want to find the proper place
for it and i
and um
he he
talks about an appendix that he that he
wanted to write for the for their report
um i'd go for a while when i can come
back the appendix would be lost but i
kept pushing on it watching it nursing
it along i finally got it through to the
point where it was at last in the hands
of a real editor capable man my name was
hansen who changed all my witches to
that's and that's two witches
mr hansen fixed up my report without
changing the sense of it then mr kiel uh
the assistant to the chairman of the
committee fixed it up so that it could
go in as an appendix he put all kinds of
big circles around whole sections with
x's through them
there were
all kinds of thoughts left out he
explained to me that my report was
repetitious with the main report i argue
it's much easier to read something
that's all together because it's going
to be an appendix it didn't matter for
repetition but anyway that's a but um
okay so there is something there is
wordsmithing going on and i find as i
as i
uh how many of my waking hours are spent
with
with uh
with things like commas and and periods
um do i consider that really
really
of no value whatsoever and um and the
answer is that i that i that i consider
uh it's a much greater percentage of my
of of what i what i really am supposed
to do in my life than i would have
believed before and that's why i'm
teaching this course this this quarter
um on the other hand i don't
you know i i i don't uh
think that it's the only thing i do and
and so when i typically when i comment
on
when i have to write notes on a
on a student thesis or
or almost anything else where i
where i have to make technical criticism
i find that
that
my comments
have a
quite a range so some of them will be
will be uh completely scientific they'll
they'll they'll say you know this
what you want is a different theorem
here or the theorem is wrong or you want
to you know or there or some will be
more strategic saying uh
how about some
motivation here's an idea for motivation
uh but many of them will be uh saying
which should be that or uh or or
something with common so it ranges all
over this
all over this uh this line but still i i
i i see that uh to if it would be a
mistake for me to say that i was going
to limit myself to any one of those
particular things i think that it's all
part of life it's all important thing
um
well
i hope this gets uh uh
circulated so that a lot of people can
read it's a neat article can i just make
a comment about simon he's pulled a good
trick being as famous as he is he has
about a dozen books in print and he
hasn't written any of them himself they
were all lectures he gave and other
people yeah i see yeah he's he's uh
extremely good at lecturing that's right
but that but wordsmithing is not one of
these things yeah no that's right
this was also this was written by uh the
same person who uh
who
ralph layton who did the uh
surely you're joking mr fein
oh he's climbing lecture the physics
studio as a freshman i used to go to his
uh advanced quantum mechanics class and
leave believing that i understood what
he talked about
yeah
well
done it's a good tradition that's what
we have of aristotle's as well
yes oh okay yeah right
[Music]
uh julia push please push the button
i had the privilege of interviewing him
when i was an archivist in los alamos oh
i have a tape recorder
of that interview
yeah yeah julia lived in los alamos for
two or three years i guess
and he he uh in his book you're joking
mr from he has wonderful stories about
uh
about how he picked the locks in los
alamos and and and it was sort of the
most important thing i mean
uh
uh i mean
the science
would have flopped if he hadn't been
able to if he hadn't been able to
circumvent the system that they had
something some of these things but it
was fun
i got busted once at margaret jackson
weekend opening a room that i wasn't
supposed to have a keith
yeah
well
yeah he came to one of my lectures i
gave a lecture at caltech on uh
backtracking and uh and i was uh really
surprised to see him sitting there in
the front row threw me for a loop there
um
but uh you quite
okay now um i've got
uh
a big handout for
for you today 50 pages long can you
believe that i want to explain that
handout to you this is going to cover
you for a little while
for
preparation
we're having guest lectures as you know
starting on wednesday for four in a row
next wednesday is jeff allman whose talk
has been advertised as
how to get rich by
by writing something like this
leslie lamport on friday nils nilsson a
week from today and then mary claire a
week from wednesday
um
uh since you you you know mary claire
from the book that you already own but i
want you to get to know some of the
other authors so i've got examples of
the writing in this handout
and i'll talk to i'll talk to you a
little more about that later first i
should say about publicity for this um
um you can tell your friends to
uh that they're all invited to you know
these are like
also like colloquia or something like
that it's a special thing that these
people will
maybe once in their life be
like
like for example jeff may never again
give a lecture on how to get rich
as an author um
and uh and leslie and so on and nils uh
so uh these are these are special uh are
special opportunities that uh
that other people who aren't taking the
course regularly might want to know
about and we didn't get into the
colloquium list for leslie we got jeff's
in there but for some reason uh they
didn't pick up on leslie's talk on
friday so like so i'd like to
to also make sure that these uh that
these special lectures are heard about
by people that
that that you know that would be
interested
um now
in this handout
um
see what else do i have here okay so in
this handout i i start out with a short
a short piece that that lamport wrote
that i
that i thought was a was an excellent um
uh example of a of a uh
of a uh
a flame but it's it's a finely done uh
thing because there's so many people
talking talking about the controversial
thing about wysiwyg languages and so on
and he's got
a way of
a way of presenting it that actually uh
does has some technical content to it so
that's a nice short little four-page
thing
now the next the next one is uh from
jeff allman's book
the uh
principles of database systems
uh jeff
i think has written
12 books by now but uh 13 and 14 are
coming out soon
and uh one of the things that he's just
putting through our typesetting machine
this month is the third edition of this
book which we'll actually have a
different title uh and it'll be a two
volumes uh set that and he's finished
the first line
it's about to come out so he's going to
use some examples
in his talk on wednesday
i mean the first part is about finances
but there's but most of it will be about
how to choose examples when you're
writing a book and he's and so this is
fresh in his mind
as he's talking and now i've i've
selected excerpts of one of the chapters
that i thought was
that that i know is well done because i
had to read it when i was on the comp
committee last year we were we had a
question that on the contact that needed
the knowledge from this chapter and so
in order to understand the question i i
had to learn this much about database
system
and uh so i i like this chapter a lot so
i show you uh
so you can read it too and see what you
see if you don't think that uh he that
it succeeds
in in getting complicated very
complicated issues uh
described very simply it also
shows me that i should make
tech easier to use to generate ruled
lines uh the book the book
some some lousy copy prep
preparation person at the publishers
went and drew these lines in here and
and they spoil the rest of the book
but
they don't look as bad on tv as they do
in the hand now
oh the so this talks about
about um rather complicated issues in
concurrent
uh
things on a database but i think it it
makes uh
extremely uh easy to understand what the
issues are and he also has a has a
little algorithm
uh that i think is a model of how to of
how to present uh uh in a short space
for for the for his readership the uh
um the uh
testing of this if the schedule can be
serialized he tells us what he explains
what serialized means algorithms
uh begins there and finishes
uh very oops
uh here's here's another thing that you
know finishes in brief time and he has a
way of of then giving and giving two
examples followed by a proof of the
algorithm
um
that it works and um anyway it seemed
that uh
that was an efficient way to present
that then he has then i then i skip
about 20 pages and i give a um something
from the end of his chapter which he
calls optimistic concurrency control and
time stamps and again he has a very nice
uh way of presenting
something that this must be much better
than in any of the sources that he had
to work with
so
worth reading
the next uh the next
excerpt in your handout is um
is by lanport again and this one is
is uh
is i think one of the best technical
reports i've seen
oh it's in the last 12 months for sure
but also uh
also maybe uh in the 80s you know
whatever that i've ever seen um
uh and uh and let me and the idea that
he introduced a style in this
in this report that's that he that
is amazingly effective uh
that i that
he hasn't used in any other papers as
far as i know neither is anybody else
but certainly ought to be ought to be uh
considered
for for more things because it works so
well even even after the novelty wears
off i believe this will be an extremely
effective way to do it so so what i want
to talk first about is not the content
of this but the
the format of it which is which is
pretty nice he has
this unseen question asker in here who
asked the questions that
he wants the reader to ask but he also
thinks probably the reader is asking at
this point and allows him to bring out
the points and so you have are you
proposing what do you mean by this you
know here it says
just what is a system
uh here's somebody so the real system
has many properties no formal method can
specify which ones can be specified and
so on he says
uh
and so i believe that he's he's
faithfully recording questions that
people ask him as he's presenting as
he's as he's talking to them in his
office and giving
so he's
he's addressing all the issues and it's
much and this is so effective as a way
to to do it you otherwise you want to
cover those same points but but this way
does it in a way that anybody can
understand and he has a nice example
um i i guess the paging is
is backwards here we have right hand
page and this is a left-hand page in the
report and uh and it's a right-hand page
for us so uh
uh so so these actually would
this illustration would be facing the
description but he talks about a machine
that uh
that dispense the deposit quarters or
half dollars and dispense it as an
example of something he wants to
formalize system he he actually has a
footnote for readers unfamiliar
with colloquial american english united
states currency he tells what soda is a
quarter and a half dollar and his
footnotes but now the main thing is the
format
now
it's not the same as as plato
plato's dialogues with uh with socrates
uh who were made was very effective in
his use of dialogue but in a way
it's not the same and that those were
games where where socrates really
is is
is trapping uh the the other people and
making them uh making them commit to
some position before they realize the
consequences of their commitments and
and uh you know
and uh uh this is different this is
teaching in a different way
where it's it's a dialogue but it's not
the same kind of a dialogue as you find
in the people in
in socratic dialogues are are going at a
different protocol
the questions get
get uh
a little longer toward the end not too
bad i mean here's a but uh it's
sometimes that there's commentary as
well as questions as this specification
is completely bizarre you know it
requires such and such how can you
possibly implement it and so on and then
answer it's bizarre only and so on
now he has a long question
which has
greek letters in it and everything so
um that's okay it gets into the form it
gets into the style
where if that if this had appeared on
the first page
um
you wouldn't have understood that this
was a you know you wouldn't have
understood that this was a nice dialogue
but by the time you're here on page 23
it's okay
this is the right way to ask the
question any guy who goes to blackboard
and puts alphas and betas on it and asks
it asks that question i haven't given
you the whole memo here but i've just
given an
excerpt so that you can see the use of
the style and if you want to read you
know if you want to learn the subject
you have to read the whole memo but this
is true
i i i encourage you to browse this for
for
for style now
i guess galileo used dialogues very
effectively in his in his scientific
writing and yeah he would have but it
was more of a
what is it trialog what is it when you
have six people in a dialogue
anyway
they had he had people i don't remember
the names of them but there was the
there was one guy whose name wasn't
exactly stupidest but it was something
like this but simple simplif simplicious
yes okay
and uh
so there are different uh personalities
among the different people in galileo
galileo's dialogue
alfred rainey
used wrote wrote a nice little book
called dialogues in applied mathematics
that has three dialogues one goes
socrates and and uh a mathematician of
of his day uh another one is archimedes
and
king chiron
syracuse and
and another one takes place
in the middle ages somewhere uh maybe
galileo is involved in that dialogue in
fact um but um and those are very well
well done where rainey is is presenting
their
his philosophy about mathematics and
by putting words into the
mouths of ancient people
but i haven't seen dialogue used very
much in technical writing um except in
george dancing's book on linear
programming where he has a chapter that
that introduced this technique as far as
i know the 20th century writing do you
know of any other examples well but it
and and i'm not sure if yeah well anyway
that was one of those that's one of the
rare cases now i i used it in in my in
my little book um surreal numbers
where there's two characters in the book
and they're known as a and b and they
allison bill and
and they they have definite
personalities that developed as the book
as the book came on and i
and i uh tried to uh and they they're
discussing things back and forth um
after after a short time i found that i
that i could really be
effective in presenting in presenting a
flow of ideas this way
uh
and and i and again i tried to be honest
these are thoughts that i actually had
as i was thinking of this
of the uh of the subject this was this
book is a presentation of
of some ideas that john conway told me
at lunch one day and and uh jotted down
on a napkin and i lost a napkin
um and a year but i decided it would be
it would be a great um
example of a
of a case study in
in
research
uh
how to do research and so i had the
characters actually inventing the
uh
reinventing conway's
uh system as they in this book meanwhile
i um i was also reconstructing it myself
from what i remembered of the
conversation we had a year ago
and so the false starts that i made and
so on are also made by the people in the
in the book as they as they um as they
do it uh this this book i i wrote in
in
six days and then i rested on the next
day i
i uh i guess i tell a little story about
it
i'm not sure but i tell this story so
often i'm not sure that i already told
it in this quote in this course no
anyway it's one of it was probably the
the most
exciting week of my life
was was the week that i wrote this book
and i but i i don't think i could ever
recapture it again uh but i look for i
look back on it still with great with
great pleasure i ran today
uh okay let's see i i discussed with my
wife we're we're on sabbatical in norway
and i discussed with my wife that
that i thought
it would be neat to write
to write a book like this
and this was
after she had already lived with me you
know for more than for about 12 years
and i've been more than 10 years i've
been working on the art of computer
programming and she knew you know i was
i wasn't done with volume 3 yet
and
and uh but i got this idea in the middle
of the night and in the morning i said
jill
i'd like to write another book uh
uh
you remember how we've been working on
this art of computer programming for 10
years and all this well all but i think
this one i can do in in a week
and and so
and uh
and so uh to my surprise she said you
know this this sounds like the right
time in your life where you could do
something like this here we are in
norway and everything and so
so uh she she was encouraging and then
and in january i i went and got a
hotel room
in
downtown oslo near where
gibson used to write his plays i thought
i would get some of the uh i'll be able
to pick up some of the uh
nuances there
and
and um
uh
we so we figured that this should be an
intensive week where i would just work
on the book and nothing else and
and we had always
read about people having affairs in
hotel rooms anyway so we planned that
she would come and visit me in hong kong
so i got this room and
and and i worked
nothing else but riding that whole that
whole week and i and uh i
i'm as they say it was it was the
greatest week in my life i i would uh
write
since i was trying to capture dialogue
in this book i i listened
to what people were saying with the
different ears than i ordinarily
listened to
um there was a whole bunch of students
from st olafs who were who were visit
who were at the same hotel
visiting norway at that time and i list
and i you know
overheard what they were talking about
at breakfast so that i could see if i
could use any of the lines in my book
then as then i go outside and i look
around and and uh the uh and i walked
around the city for two or three hours
in the afternoon every day because it
was um
okay i in the morning i would write and
and um and i would write pretty fast and
then also and i run into a problem that
was sort of insurmountable what to do
next
and and um go outside
uh and just walk around the city for a
couple of hours
and uh
and uh get my head cleared
and
and uh at this point i'm i'm much more
perceptive to to trees and flowers and
leaves and buildings and everything else
just because i'm writing about things
you just went the fact that you're that
you're uh that you're that you're
writing and trying to capture something
in word makes you sort of force you to
be more perceptive about the about the
world around you
and um so that was so i was going
through this and then i would
then i would um uh
come back to my hotel all of a sudden
the problem would resolve itself
magically and and i and i would you know
have a nice relaxing supper in the
evening
um
uh the time it comes time for for lights
out
uh i mean it's time to go to sleep after
all and uh still um i so i turn out the
lights and then
the next chapter flashes into my mind
and and i and i have to turn back this
thing on you know i don't even
try not to put on my glasses and
everything and
we didn't want to wait that long but i
have to write it down and i go and the
thoughts are coming so fast that i don't
have time to write down the words but i
can only write down the first letter of
every of every word you know so i'm i'm
going down
writing the first of every word then i
turn the lights off
sleep sleep very well so the next
morning
i have to figure out what those first
letters meant you know it came out okay
and i'm ready to go for the next day and
everything and it and this was six days
and then at the end and at the end of
the last of the sixth day i uh
uh
went and uh
took a walk that in the king's garden
beautiful tree i mean i just can't
tell you how ha that was how pleasant it
was a poor frost on the trees the
sky was a deep blue i i was i i gazed up
at these trees uh in ecstasy for an hour
just wandering around in this garden but
i had finished the book too
and i was really happy and i and on the
seventh day i tried to write a letter to
phyllis to tell her how to type this
manuscript and i couldn't write a single
sentence i get into the middle of a
sentence and it was just like russell
baker i couldn't finish the sentence i
couldn't remember what the point of it
was going to be and so on all of a
sudden this muse that had been sitting
over my shoulder for six days
disappeared
and um
finally i got the letter written and and
got the things manuscripts sent off and
you know but this was uh this was uh
something special for now i now uh the
book hasn't been a
commercial success uh it's it sells
about uh 200 copies a year i think
something like that
for
10 years
15 years but uh
but the publishers are very nice in fact
just to keep it in print
uh but it's been translated into about
seven languages and and uh i know a lot
of people have have used it in classes
and did like it but it hasn't had to
take the world by storm it's anyway it's
it it was an opening thing for me
first of all to understand a little bit
about uh
about how how writing a a um in a in a
novel format increases perception
secondly
how a dialogue format can increase the
the ability to to make technical points
very efficiently so
the next handout here is
from nilsson's engineers new book
that just came out recently
a logical foundation of ai and this was
based on the course they taught last
year in the class notes and everything
and the students went through those and
and
made lots of suggestions so that they
could they could go through and and i'm
giving you an example here one of the
chapter that that i know they found
hardest to write and and uh and so they
they drafted it
several times and
um
and i think uh
it's it's a it's a it's a hot research
area in ai and it's all and it's
something that hadn't been ever
presented before to
an audience at the level of this of this
book
here it is already in chapter six and
they had to really
uh rethink all the ideas in in order to
get them presented well so here i think
is is uh
one of the one of the great
pieces of technical writing being able
to take this
this uh
this new thing and and and present it in
a way that uh that is done well the
choice of examples is good the way they
the way the way things go uh hang
together um with examples and the
informal and formal
combinations all done extremely well
um i
uh so i've again covered sample pages
here so that you can you can
see how they
how they achieved it and
um
talking about
circumscription and all these ideas now
here he has um
uh theorem this is my only complaint
here there should have been a space
after the theorem that
we should i should
i attempted to cut this out with the
scissors and slide it up before we made
this handout
but
but he has this has a result which he's
given by examples and then he you know
he discusses the importance of the fear
and then he proves it then he gives an
example examples of its use and it's all
it's all um as i say
uh
done with with the right level of of of
uh formality versus informality it seems
to me another thing in this book that
they had to work hard on was innovations
on typography how they were going to
present logical formulas in a way that
in a way that looked reasonable and they
chose this typewriter style font for it
um and that's it actually works well in
their examples the way they the way the
way they can
have something that looks like it's it's
it's uh
comes from a database knowledge base
because it's in a typewriter or into a
terminal like like style it's more
effective i think than than the
alternatives so that's worth looking at
now the last handoff here
is um
is uh extracts from a paper that that i
was
uh co-author of and uh
and i actually wrote the final text of
the of the article
and
this is something that
that um
presents two dif
two difficult theorems as far as i know
there are no simple proofs of these
theorems
and i present this handout just uh to
to illustrate what i thought was a
a
somewhat innovative way to
uh to solve the problem of proving the
theorem now i haven't made the proofs of
the theorems trivial but in this
presentation
as far as i know there's no way to do
that but i think i have been able to
communicate
uh
the the proofs that we had in the in the
most effective way by the by the ways
that i chose in this thing so let me
explain what that is and then you can
judge for yourself now the first theorem
was an algorithm was it was it was a
construction uh telling how we could
decide if a if a graph could be put
together into a straight line in such a
way that you never had to
stretch any of the wires more than
length two
um
so what i want to do is
i want to take these and and i present
this with an example here i have twenty
seven letters isn't it xyz and ampersand
and uh
so these 27 letters are to be put into a
straight line in such a way that any two
that are adjacent are uh i mean are
connected by a line here
are either supposed to be next to each
other or or
or most one apart
in the final in the final
thing so you could you know from j to k
to l
to o
in the final thing uh you might have you
might actually have k before j and then
l after because that was j the k
you can still skip one to get to l but
you can't but you couldn't have uh
uh
you know you can't have too many things
you can't have anything you know almost
one more letter between j and k one one
k l now the point that i'm trying to
make here is that um the only way i
could think of to motivate the uh the
construction that we're giving is by
first presenting the reader with a with
this little puzzle
and anybody i think this is the kind of
puzzle that you could put into an
airline magazine or uh or you know
a puzzle column uh brain teaser type of
thing uh people can easily get the idea
you can solve it in 10-15 minutes and
after you've and after you've done it
it's not it's unpleasant 10 or 15
minutes and after you've done it uh you
will understand
why the problem
isn't
is uh
isn't completely trivial but you'll also
understand that there might very well be
an algorithm that would solve the
problem so this presents this gives you
all the all the
intuitions that you need in order to
read the next pages
um
and uh
so
so then i present uh an algorithm now
the algorithm itself is the worst
algorithm the most complicated algorithm
that i've ever had to present and as far
as i know there is no simpler algorithm
and
so
this next page here presents the the end
of the algorithm i don't give you the
algorithm itself i didn't have it i
didn't dare
but notice this here case
3.4.5.3.3.3 now
uh you know we we're into a bunch of
cases here and and um
uh
this is this as far as i know these
cases are all are all necessary
and uh and so somebody put actually put
this up on the computer science bulletin
board
a few months ago and i took it down
but had made this little note on here it
says only in computer science
and so obviously
you know
uh making some kind of a reference so
here i was but as far as i know there's
no better way to present this algorithm
and there and
and it's very true this is only in
computer science i mean somehow
um a bill
the ability to handle lots of cases is
the
is is computer scientists strength and
weakness it's it's a strength in that
that we we seem to be able to handle a
variety of cases uh uh fluently uh in
our in our daily work we have to be able
to uh uh to to write computer programs
that that involve uh uh ten different
kinds of operators that we're allowed to
do and these are diverse from each other
we handled this this kind of complexity
uh reasonably well that's probably why
we we became computer scientists
on the other hand it's a great weakness
too because then we don't try
for unity when there is unity as much we
aren't encouraged to like if we were we
were more pure mathematicians we
wouldn't uh be we wouldn't handle this
we wouldn't consider this even an option
to have this many cases and so we would
never solve the problem
that needs cases but what what if we get
to a problem that doesn't need cases
we'll still come up with a solution that
has them so that's our strength and
weakness i think with computer science
so it's a true it's a true comment for
sure but uh this was uh as far as i know
the the only way to prove the thing and
i and i was able to still boil down and
make the cases
um
understandable anybody who needs to know
and actually we had people who read this
believe it or not um
but uh but but basically you get the
idea by solving that puzzle so that so
that was the the idea there was uh
presenting the little puzzle at the
beginning the puzzle was chosen in such
some way that it could be done but also
it also primed
plan for the rest of it now the other
the other theorem was was was also very
difficult but not but completely
different way by the way i get to use
the
puzzle to describe the algorithm as well
i i mean i can
i can
use that that that figure and then show
how the algorithm solves the problem uh
mechanically
now but the second
uh
the second part is another
result a construction of a different
kind
called tree bandwidth is np complete and
this
this is a a reduction of one problem to
another that that uh requires
a
quite a complicated construction of of
of graphs
now
um
and and
and these were theorems that uh that my
co-authors had invented and it took me a
long time to understand what was going
on
but we decided to put this all together
in the same paper
and uh so i decided so if finally after
thinking about it a lot how would i ever
present this in a way that that anybody
could really under that could understand
uh
finally i
i i came to the uh realization that
maybe
maybe people in biology aren't so stupid
as i had thought before namely
the people in biology have all these
have all these words that um that's that
looked like complete gobbledygook to me
and there and you know dna
used to be that you had to know
not only that there were four things in
dna but each one of them had a six
syllable name or something like that
didn't it i mean now they finally
abbreviated the letters but at the first
part you know you you knew them by these
long names and i always thought that was
you know that was really strange
um
however uh in this paper it occurred it
it turned out that it was easier for me
to actually use this technique from
biology uh and a little bit and so and i
was dealing with with things like in
computer science we would normally call
tree structures uh which uses botany
turns from um
from that part of nature but but it but
actually these things were
were more floating than uh than rooted
and so
uh it so i went to the encyclopedia and
i found out that what i really wanted
was um
jellyfish
or i mean something which uh the
the uh
so i of course i'm writing a scientific
paper so i talk about pelagic hydrozoa
you know of the orders on a flora i'm
trying to be very scientific here but i
got over that in a hurry but
but um
but really then i say marine biology so
the free trees we shall construct there
more resemblance to pelagic this is
swimming
uh and hydrozoa are these uh things that
go in the water and animals in the water
right zolan is animal and so on and this
is an order of cyphenophora which is uh
includes jellyfish and a bunch of other
things things and so we find it
convenient to use terms for marine
biology in botany and so that so then i
talk about the things and these things
have stems and polyps and tentacles
and um and and a word like tentacle
especially is is reasonably easy to
identify with somehow uh when you're
like when you're like when you were
doing it now
um
and the uh and there were filament and
then the
and then the important thing here is the
pneumaticists
now this is a word that has not appeared
in computer science journals before
it really means stingers
yeah
um and i could have called it the
stingers but i decided it was better to
call them the nematocists
i don't even know how to pronounce it
but i'm assuming the matter this is
right
and but having this word
um
was very easy to read the rest of it
because you knew what in the i mean you
could i don't know we were fairly good
at picking up that kind of a word and
being able to to
to uh
associate it with the tentacle and uh
and and it became a technical word that
was abused only in this paper but still
uh i believe uh was was absolutely uh
better than
than than calling it a
group of vertices or some other
you know some some other uh term that
had been used before
so so by by using a
a completely new term just for the
purpose of this paper
uh still it was possible to uh
to get the points across i think in a
way that's better that's uh it was
easier to follow the proof and the rest
of the proof then could be could be read
my opinion
i'll marry claire
if it turns out that this result is more
generally useful are you going to be sad
that you call it pneumaticist rather
than stinger no i don't think so
i am maybe i would
but then i would tell the people let's
call them stingers
um yeah i don't know
i am sad you know i was sad about
terminology before you know
that is
one of my first papers i wrote talked
about a
kind of
language called lr of k
grammars and i never
realized that this was going to become a
subject in textbooks and things like
that i just needed
something that meant translation from
left to right with look ahead k and i
forgot
and i just uh without any thought
whatsoever i just need an abbreviation
for it so i said lr for nk
and uh then this turned out to be a big
subject for a lot of research for the
next 10 years or something like this and
and
i didn't really
since i hadn't given much thought to it
i didn't you know it was already there
though there was no way to no way to
change it anymore so so five years later
i
tried to think of a justification for
having that many letters why did i just
call it l of k or something like this
you see
and um so so five years later i thought
of a way to define something else that
could be
that could be l l of k and and r l of k
and r r of k
and so then we had a family of four
related methods uh that could be
understood in some
to have some some logical sense to them
but actually it didn't in in original
and uh and i and i sort of just forced
myself afterward to think of a logical
sense and well it seems to come out okay
in the end
um
but i wasn't proud of it at the
beginning at all
yeah good point
now
um so i won't have
okay now uh ramsay please
uh push the like button
wasn't there wasn't there some time in
volume one or volume two in like a first
edition you used some terminology but
everyone else everyone else was using
another one and i changed it yeah this
was uh i think the most uh dramatic
example of this was in volume 3 where
where um
with respect to the word oracle
um
and uh
and i had originally decided to call it
call it demons instead but everyone in
the in in theoretical computer science
was was using the idea of an oracle an
oracle is some
is somebody who um uh if you have if you
have a question to ask you ask the
article and the article tells you the
answer and the oracle might have more
computational power than
than you do so so you say how fast can i
solve this if i have an oracle helping
me
um this is uh and but i had um
i in my original draft i had i used the
word demon instead of of oracle it was
there was no general thing for this and
uh
and so i got um
help from the underworld in the original
case but finally uh the new one
is in terms of oracle and besides which
ai picked up demons for something else
so so not only was i you know not using
the right word for but i but the word i
used uh became something uh
especially uh in uh
at mit i think there were demons all
over the place in certain ai languages i
don't know anymore about demons but uh
but they they were uh anyways um so i so
there i had to to to uh change it i
don't know if it was between the first
and second printing or if it was or if i
got to if i got to change in before the
before the book came out now now in case
of of ajo hof cross and almond there's a
the uh there was a last minute change of
terminology
at this time was 1973
and
all this things about np complete was
was was was brand new in fact people
weren't calling it np complete they were
calling it polynomial complete
and uh and the uh
and everybody who was first hearing this
term polynomial polynomially complete
was completely misunderstanding in it
because it really meant that you
couldn't do things in polynomial time
time unless unless a conjecture that's
probably false is true and so it was
just you know it was it was not a
right a right term and so i wrote to
people
uh um the same year while i'm in norway
i was i also wrote letters i was giving
lectures on this at
uh in oslo to to learn it myself and uh
so i wrote the people saying look
here's a choice of of six different
terms uh should we call these herculean
problems
um oh you know what else what and and
other people were suggested to name to
name problems one of them was called
algae and i think was one of them and
people who know classic so
those problems cleaning the stables well
um anyway uh we had various things and
and finally uh and so we had we had a uh
the theoretical computer scientists of
the world sort of voting on a
questionnaire what should we call this
thing and the winner was np hard and np
complete
um and this will form a large set of
interesting options that that came out
and uh and and jeff allman had just uh
their book off to the publisher
and uh we were at the galley proof
reading stages and they said oh gosh
it's just too late we can't possibly
make all the changes from polynomial
complete to np complete everywhere in
our book
um and it's too bad but you know it's
just it's too late and uh but
i was very glad to see two months later
when the book actually came out that
they had they had gone through and did
all that hard work and changed every
place and it came out np complete and
the name
and the good name stuck then
so
so um yeah uh there are cases where
where you when you expect the
terminology is going to live that you
want to really give it some thought and
in this case the masses i don't know
i don't think it's going to
live you